I wanted to think I'm not going crazy
like I'm doing all this press around the
world for the first few years I've been
involved in things before and I know
when something's popular and this felt
incredibly popular but it didn't feel
like Fox ever recognized that for
whatever reason I don't know um but it
was popular never happens yeah and and
again you know I've been told by Peter
Roth and other people this never happens
this never happens this never happens
there's so many bad facets of of social
media but they're good facets you know
they good parts to it and you know this
without social media this wouldn't have
happened oh no without a shadow and I
I'm the same as you I have hugely mixed
feelings about social media I want to be
private um and protect things privately
and I think feel like going on social
media you're just leaving yourself open
to anything um and but at the same time
I wouldn't be here probably talking to
you about this thing right now if it
hadn't been for social media